[Música]
más de 50 años de conflicto en colombia
que involucró a diferentes sectores de
la sociedad de ese país y que también
costó la vida de miles de personas quedó
por decirlo de alguna manera consignado
de cierta forma en ese informe de la
comisión de la verdad que dio a conocer
de manera exhaustiva detalles del
conflicto que enfrentó al gobierno de
colombia y al entonces grupo rebelde de
la guerrilla de las farc un paso
importante para la reconciliación de
colombia también representa un cierre de
ese capítulo oscuro de su historia pero
vamos entonces a ponerlos en contexto
rápidamente vamos a hacer un repaso por
lo que es esta comisión de la verdad en
colombia su origen tiene lugar en el
marco de los acuerdos de paz del 2016 un
acuerdo que fue alcanzado entonces por
el estado colombiano y la antigua
guerrilla de las farc su misión pues
examinar el conflicto colombiano desde
1958 hasta el 2016 este informe es el
primero en ser publicado mientras el
conflicto todavía está en curso porque
colombia todavía tiene unos
acuerdos o pactos o conversaciones
pendientes con grupos guerrilleros y con
otros grupos armados en ese país esto
forma parte del sistema integral de paz
y junto a la unidad de búsqueda de
personas dadas por desaparecidas y
también la jurisdicción especial para la
paz esta última es la única que tiene
vinculación judicial en su toma de
decisiones por lo que sus objetivos son
simplemente el esclarecimiento el
reconocimiento la convivencia y la no
repetición un relato que sirva a los
colombianos para saber qué fue lo que
pasó en su país el mandato de la
comisión de la verdad empezó el 28 de
noviembre de 2018 y debía tener una
vigencia de tres años pero fue
prolongado debido a la pandemia de kobe
19 que prácticamente paralizó todas las
actividades no sólo en colombia ción en
diferentes países del mundo la entrega
del informe tiene lugar el 28 de junio y
hasta el 28 de agosto será socializado
en diferentes actividades a lo largo y
ancho de ese país suramericano la
comisión ha recolectado cerca de 30.000
testimonios no solamente en colombia
sino en 23 países alrededor del mundo y
en ellos han sido entre listadas
personas que pertenecen a los diferentes
sectores de la sociedad colombiana que
estuvieron inmersos en este conflicto la
mayoría de ellas son víctimas este grupo
de víctimas ha sido afectada en un 37
por ciento por acciones de la guerrilla
un 32% por acciones del paramilitarismo
un 14% por la fuerza pública y un 17%
por otros actores armados en ese país
este informe cuenta con 10 capítulos
tiene también una declaración del padre
francisco de quien es presidente de la
comisión de la verdad estas fueron sus
palabras en la entrega o presentación de
este informe hoy traemos una palabra que
viene de escuchar y sentir a las
víctimas en gran parte del territorio y
en el exilio
de oír a quienes luchan por mantener la
memoria y resistir al negacionismo ya
quienes han aceptado
responsabilidades éticas políticas y
penales
un mensaje de verdad para detener la
tragedia intolerable de un conflicto en
que el 80% de las víctimas eran civiles
no combatientes
bueno pero como está estructurado este
documento cuáles son esos capítulos se
los cuento rápidamente el primero
hallazgo y recomendaciones para la no
repetición estas eran unas sugerencias
que no son vinculantes judicialmente
para que el gobierno entrante las ponga
en práctica y con el fin de evitar que
vuelva a suceder pues lo que ha venido
presentando colombia a lo largo de estas
cinco décadas también el segundo punto
son las violaciones a los derechos
humanos y al derecho internacional
humanitario' 3 narrativa histórica 4
territorio 5 mujeres y población lgtb 6
étnico 7 exilio estos tres últimos
capítulos de género y de diversidad
étnica y exilio aparecen por primera vez
en una comisión de la verdad alrededor
del mundo y 8 el punto número 8 son
niños niñas adolescentes y jóvenes el
punto número 9 volumen testimonial un
novedoso capítulo que tendrá relatos
de las víctimas y el último capítulo es
impactos y afrontamiento también
resistencias y también será la primera
vez que se dedica un capítulo a las
alianzas comunitarias que han resistido
este conflicto a lo largo de más de
cinco décadas en este evento pues estuvo
presente el presidente electo de
colombia gustavo petro y también su
fórmula vicepresidencial electa francia
márquez y brilló por su ausencia el
presidente saliente iván duque su
gobierno recordemos no ha sido un gran
aliado de la implementación del acuerdo
de paz y por ende de esta comisión
recordemos algunas de las palabras del
presidente electo de los colombianos
gustavo petro esto fue lo que dijo
cortar los ciclos de la venganza es lo
mismo que cortar los ciclos de la
violencia
y entonces la verdad tiene un sentido
que no es la de la venganza sino que es
la del diálogo
sino que es la del acuerdo sino que es
la de la convivencia sino que es la
reconciliación
este gobierno podrá tener un éxito y
quizás muchas de estas recomendaciones
que ahora leeré podrán ser prácticas
eficaces
que sigue entonces para la construcción
de paz en colombia' qué alcance tiene
este informe cómo se van a implementar
esas recomendaciones que plantea el
documento que tanto aporta esto para la
reconciliación y la no repetición de
este conflicto son preguntas que quedan
sobre la mesa pero hay cientos de puntos
que podríamos analizar de este informe
por eso hoy en el debate de france 24
colombia histórico informe de la
comisión de la verdad comienzan a sanar
las heridas para analizar este tema
saludamos a daniela gómez ellas
consultora en derechos humanos paz y
conflicto armado ya se encuentra en la
ciudad de bogotá la capital colombiana y
aquí en el estudio de france 24 nos
acompaña camilo umaña él es consultor de
acceso a justicia e impunidad de la
comisión de la verdad y docente
investigador del departamento de derecho
constitucional de la universidad
externado de colombia les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación dejen todas sus preguntas
sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales estamos en twitter en instagram
y en facebook en donde nos encuentran
como france24 guión bajo s
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
en youtube también pueden encontrar
nuestra señal en streaming también los
invito para que escuchen el podcast de
nuestro programa de todo nuestro
contenido que está disponible en app el
podcast en spotify deezer y tune in pues
bueno vamos entonces a comenzar a
analizar este tema importante para la
historia colombiana comenzó entonces con
daniela gómez en la ciudad de bogotá
bienvenida a daniela gracias por
acompañarnos primera pregunta me gusta
llamarla el punto de partida que es para
conocer las impresiones de los invitados
y le preguntó entonces por en su
perspectiva lo que significa este
informe para este proceso de
construcción de paz que tiene colombia
lo que significa este 28 de junio para
la historia del conflicto colombiano y
la construcción de paz
pues digamos que tiene muchos
significados como mecanismo de justicia
transicional pues es un elemento muy
importante
dentro de los demás o dentro del sistema
integral de verdad justicia y reparación
digamos que la memoria que es lo que se
ha trabajado en colombia ampliamente lo
que tenía como pretensión el centro
nacional de memoria histórica es una
visión subjetiva
sobre
y las diferentes historias formas de ver
lo que nos pasó la comisión de la verdad
por el contrario y una aprensión
pretensión subjetiva científica
esclarecedora digamos que por más que se
hace que se mantenga el hecho de que no
puede existir un relato oficial la el
relato de una comisión de la verdad si
tiene pretensiones de ser un relato
digamos desde el estado desde una
institución transicional claro
y que pues cuya idea es permitir
justamente el la reconciliación y
esas miradas hacia atrás para poder
avanzar al futuro un futuro de
experiencia la opinión y punto de
partida de daniela comenzó en la ciudad
de bogotá y aquí en el estudio de france
24 ya lo decía me acompaña a camilo
umaña camilo gracias por acompañarnos
hoy en el programa punto de partida sus
impresiones además usted estuvo allí en
la lectura de este informe qué significa
esto para colombia
muchas gracias ante algún saludo de
niell a
en este informe significa un intento
institucional por vencer los silencios
que se han instalado a lo largo del
conflicto armado sobre las violencias y
las responsabilidades pero también
tratar de bajar los índices de negación
y de mentira que se han trazado con
respecto al conflicto armado las
víctimas y los perpetradores se busca en
la comisión siempre se habló que la
institución buscaba a ser una especie de
partera de la verdad allí no se agota la
verdad allí no se origina toda la verdad
pero es un punto de partida para pensar
y para discutir las múltiples verdades
con ocasión del conflicto armado en
últimas este informe
significa para la sociedad colombiana
una oportunidad una oportunidad de ver
al pasado con miras a no repetir las
violencias y con una esperanza de paz
camilo continuo con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa ya le doy la palabra
daniela usted dice oportunidad para la
sociedad colombiana pero la sociedad
colombiana a lo largo de estos años se
ha mostrado muy polarizada y lo veíamos
en el momento de la votación sobre el
acuerdo de paz y hay muchas opiniones en
torno a su implementación
recibe la sociedad colombiana este
informe publicado ha dado a conocer como
bien dice santiago el informe busca
hablarle a la sociedad en su conjunto no
solamente a las instituciones y la
sociedad en su conjunto tiene un
problema de polarización por supuesto
cinco décadas de violencia al menos
instalados tienen unas lógicas de
confrontación de enemigo interno de
asuntos que no se han resuelto por
largas décadas sin embargo esta sociedad
debe aprender en curso de estos
problemas para saber dar unas soluciones
específicas sabemos que este conflicto
se intergeneracional ha tenido un
impacto en muchas generaciones y nos
corresponde ahora pensar para las
generaciones venideras qué tipo de
sociedad vamos a dejar daniela en la
ciudad de bogotá la verdad es importante
para un país conocer lo que ha sucedido
a lo largo de estas cinco décadas que
tanto esto puede ayudar para empezar a
generar consensos para enrutar a la
sociedad colombiana en un solo camino
para no repetir estos actos que se han
venido dando en colombia a lo largo de
estas hincada décadas
digamos que la verdad si es muy
importante no solo
en el mecanismo digamos extrajudicial
sino también en el mecanismo judicial
que significará la guerra
para bajar los niveles de impunidad
y claro que esto propicia sobre todo
siempre un diálogo entre la sociedad que
permite ampliar un horizonte moral
del discurso como bien digamos lo ha
retomado la comisión y creo que
profundizaron ampliamente en ello hay
una hay una parte digamos ética moral
que yace en la sociedad como conjunto y
ahorita que hablabas de la polarización
y de lo complejo que puede llegar a ser
para la sociedad recibir esto pues yo
creo que lo que más va a ser y tal vez
esta verdad es propiciar el diálogo tal
vez alrededor de una polarización sí
pero eso no implica que nos empiecen a
ampliar el horizonte valora tu moral de
la sociedad te pongo un ejemplo al
inicio del
proceso de paz los opositores estaban
rechazando ampliamente la paz una vez
empiezan a bajar los índices de
homicidio
con el agrupamiento ya en los espacios
de transitorios de las farc
pues digamos que les tiene que cambiar
el discurso y también se amplía su moral
y ya no es la paz no sino la paz sí pero
no así y vamos viendo cómo vamos como
sociedad incluso entre la polarización
encontrando puntos de encuentro y eso
está propiciado alrededor de todos estos
este mirarnos pues a nosotros mismos y a
nuestra sociedad ya nuestra historia
daniela en este capítulo es muy
significativo para colombia ya lo
estábamos diciendo entonces cómo va a
ser ese impulso para la construcción de
paz y más allá de la construcción de paz
en colombia que es un proceso que viene
lento con un apoyo sin apoyo del
gobierno generar una cultura de paz en
la sociedad colombiana a partir de lo
que ha sucedido hoy de este informe esto
es un impulso para esa construcción como
lo que usted de un primer paso o
simplemente un pequeño ladrillo si no
creo que el simple hecho de sacar esto
al debate público de ver tantos digamos
líderes de opinión medios de
comunicación academia
las comunidades la base porque creo que
en eso también hizo un gran trabajo la
atención de la verdad y el sistema en
general
pues va a propiciar esos diálogos
adicionalmente pues según pude ver por
encima no podía leer obviamente las
recomendaciones pues hay también unos
apartados muy específicos sobre la
memoria sobre
el arte y la cultura también el papel
que debería jugar en este futuro
diferente que el que sugiere la comisión
de la verdad en este capítulo y por acá
en el estudio camilo un impulso a la
construcción de la paz oa la
construcción de esa cultura de la paz
cuál puede ser primero o el paso más
necesario que necesita colombia en este
momento en que no me han existido
históricamente múltiples iniciativas de
paz de resistencias afrontamiento desde
las comunidades y también las
instituciones el mismo estado ha tratado
muchas veces de zanjar diferencias a
través de diferentes acuerdos muchas
veces han sido acuerdos que no se han
cumplido muchas veces han sido acuerdos
que han llevado a ciertos avances somos
una generación hija de la constitución
del 91 que hace parte también de muchos
de esos acuerdos y esto involucra pensar
que en la comisión de la verdad no es el
punto de llegada ni tampoco es un punto
de partida sino es un punto más en una
larga trayectoria de mucha parte de la
sociedad civil colombiana que ha buscado
construir esa paz y la paz se construye
no solamente con un pasado sino también
en un presente con una proyección hacia
el futuro el papel de las comunidades el
papel de la sociedad civil para ello va
a ser muy importante de poder retomar
las recomendaciones de asimilar las
lecciones del informe y también exigirle
no solamente el ejecutivo sino al estado
de su conjunto y a la sociedad en
general una realmente afrontamiento esta
violencia para que nos lleven una
cultura de paz apropiada esto requiere
compromisos camilo y algo de lo que
llama la atención por lo menos fuera de
las fronteras de colombia es la falta de
compromiso digámoslo así que ha tenido
el gobierno del presidente de duke para
el desarrollo de esta comisión y en
general para el acuerdo de paz en sí
quien significa que esta comisión haya
presentado este informe el día de hoy
tres años después de esta investigación
de haber recorrido el país de arriba a
abajo haber logrado sacar estas
conclusiones y recomendaciones sin haber
tenido un soporte amplio del estado
colombiano
era previsible pero no por ello deja de
ser absolutamente decepcionante la
fuerza política que impulsó el voto por
el no el plebiscito
quedó elegida como
liderando a una parte muy importante del
estado que es el ejecutivo en colombia
un régimen muy marcadamente
presidencialista en eso y llevó a que
fuera un gobierno que estuviera atrapado
en la ambigüedad de tener que cumplir
unos acuerdos que había mellado en la
campaña política y que incluso había
dicho textualmente que iba a deshacer o
destruir esto pues implicó una sin
salida y el gobierno siempre estuvo
dubitativo y ambiguo tratando de mostrar
internacionalmente una suerte de
cumplimiento pero en lo nacional y sobre
todo en lo local pues grandes índices de
incumplimiento de lo que es el acuerdo
en lo que involucra que estamos ante un
acuerdo que no se ha implementado
realmente en un porcentaje satisfactorio
estamos en un gobierno que va a hacer un
cambio
y que ni siquiera asistió a la entrega
del informe final sí ya lo vamos a
analizar es un punto importante que el
presidente duque no haya estado presente
en la presentación de este informe
daniela es significativo que este
informe sea presentado en este momento
cuando sea una transición de gobierno a
partir del 7 de agosto colombia va a
recibir un nuevo presidente va a recibir
a gustavo petro como presidente es
significativo la presencia de petro allí
en la entrega y presentación de este
informe para su desarrollo para su
implementación para tener en cuenta las
recomendaciones que análisis puede hacer
usted
y es sumamente digamos significativo y
yo creo que para la sociedad también
creo que un poco lo que se expresó en
las urnas era esta voluntad de
implementación del acuerdo de paz de
mirar unos territorios que han sido
sistemáticamente excluidos
y cuya configuración digamos
territorial y demás nunca nunca
favoreció ni ha interesado en la
construcción o compromiso real de los
entes estatales allí
entonces creo que la llegada de o sea la
entrega es del informe a un nuevo
gobierno pues es en una coyuntura muy
precisa y tipo y seguramente será será
hoja de ruta
para la presidencia que comienza no le
queda muy difícil ha gustado petro
deseen marcarse de los compromisos son
las recomendaciones que allí se hacen
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta pues qué
es lo que sigue en la comisión será ésta
este grupo de personas que va a hacerle
seguimiento a la implementación de las
recomendaciones
y daniela su opinión sobre la ausencia
del presidente duque del presidente
saliente que está en europa y ya lleva
varias semanas por fuera del país casi
20 días ausente del territorio
colombiano
pues la verdad creo que le faltó mucha
grandeza para ver el momento histórico
que estamos viviendo
no hay muchas comisiones de la verdad en
el mundo y está sin duda pues creo que
es la más completa que se ha hecho hasta
el momento no solamente eso sino para
nuestra sociedad es sumamente relevante
conocer nuestro pasado y pues afrontarlo
no y yo creo que es un poco lo que ha
significado el gobierno de duques y
negacionismo que es como si él estuviera
en un universo paralelo como si no se
diera cuenta de verdad de lo que le está
pasando por el frente
pero tampoco creo que haya hecho falta
sabes como hoy fue mucho más
significativo el recibimiento por parte
de petro que lo que podría haber sido el
recibimiento del informe por parte de
duque creería yo por este lado camelo su
opinión ausencia de eduque presencia de
petro significativo para el mensaje que
se le envía a los colombianos y le añado
otra parte de la pregunta a partir de
este punto en el que estamos quién nivel
quien debe liberar liderar esto el
estado la sociedad
a partir de dónde empiezan a marcharse
los puntos para continuar en este camino
de construcción de paz el destinatario
del informe de la comisión del orden la
sociedad en su conjunto no solamente
nacionales e incluso internacionales por
ende el ejecutivo no es el único
destinatario de este informe lo cierto
es que es muy llamativo que el ejecutivo
encabeza el presidente actual no haya
asistido creo que hay no recuerdo algún
ejemplo una comisión de la verdad en la
historia en la cual el el presidente no
haya asistido a la entrega y esto es un
rasgo absolutamente decepcionante y se
suma a la lista de ausencias de
institucionalidad y del gobierno
nacional en muchos de los temas sobre
todo relacionados con el tema de paz la
presencia del presidente electo petro
lanza un mensaje de una apuesta hacia el
gobierno futuro de llevar esas
recomendaciones y traducirlas de alguna
forma a la política pública pero es
bastante preocupante para un país como
colombia que no hay una reflexión
institucional más allá de una reflexión
de los gobiernos cómo es que la política
de paz
una política de estado sino que varía de
una forma tan radical de un gobierno a
otro como es que un gobierno saliente no
cumple con sus compromisos en materia de
derechos humanos y de garantía de la paz
y al menos asiste al acto de lanzamiento
del informe entonces esto es bastante
eficiente y tristemente elocuente además
que como lo decía yo en la introducción
del programa
es muy particular el caso colombiano
porque presentan este informe de esta
comisión de la verdad pero el conflicto
colombiano sigue abierto hay muchos
otros capítulos que hay que
avanzar con lln con otros grupos armados
o que delinquen al margen de la ley como
entiende uno ese contexto es
completamente sui generis yo no lo
comparaba con otros países que han
tenido experiencias similares con una
comisión de la verdad que está este
informe se plantean unos puntos para no
repetir pero el país sigue en un
conflicto abierto estamos viviendo una
transmutación del conflicto armado en
donde tenemos diferentes actores y
factores que han hecho que se
multipliquen en muchos escenarios la
violencia
muchas comunidades no han recibido
grandes beneficios del acuerdo de paz
mientras otras han visto su vida y su
tranquilidad mejorar es necesario
entender que lo que ocurre hoy en día en
colombia es que tenemos un conflicto en
curso al menos cerca de 10 conflictos
armados internos y muchísimas bandas que
ejercen control sobre diferentes zonas
del territorio no solamente en la
ruralidad sino también en las grandes
ciudades
esto implica un reto enorme en materia
de justicia de política de derechos
humanos un riesgo institucional y
también para la sociedad en su conjunto
diríamos que una comisión que le hable a
un problema que está ocurriendo y tiene
un problema muy grande de cómo traducir
o cómo poder ayudar a pasar la página
claro está pero también hace muy
pertinentes sus observaciones es decir
las las recomendaciones y lo que nos
muestra la comisión de la verdad tal vez
pueda brindarnos claves para justamente
resolver un problema muy actual no es un
problema del pasado sino es algo que
estamos viviendo en nuestro país ya está
en curso eso no pone en riesgo daniela
y ese parámetro de la no repetición que
el país todavía está en un conflicto no
pone en riesgo que el estado o los
actores involucrados
terminen repitiendo justamente lo que se
pide que no ocurra en este informe de la
comisión de la verdad
por supuesto y más allá digamos que sean
los mismos actores los que constituyen
la violencia también que llegue no es
así nosotros vivimos como un continuo de
violencia en colombia es su historia es
un continuo de violencia y yo creo que
ahí es muy importante justamente el
llamado que hace la comisión de la
verdad para lo que denominó el padre de
imagínese está en su informe la paz
grande y no que esa paz no sólo pues con
las farc sino con todos los grupos y
como sociedad
ahora también creo que va a ser muy
importante las recomendaciones que puede
hacer la comisión respecto al enfoque de
seguridad que es algo que no se ha visto
tanto dentro de las estrategias de paz
pero es algo que requiere este estado de
manera digamos urgente aquí seguimos
parados sobre unas unas dos premisas
muy antiguas de
la lógica de la violencia y la lógica
digamos militar de las complete acciones
armadas
está todo instalado como la idea de un
enemigo interno y más allá del enemigo
interno la idea de
de una utilización también de las
comunidades a favor de la estrategia de
seguridad y no la estrategia de
seguridad a favor de las unidades
entonces es paso acabado mucho la
confianza en el nivel mixto como más
micro en lo más local que es realmente
donde se definen las dimensiones de la
violencia y la magnitud de la misma
entonces mientras el estado no cambie
estas políticas de seguridad pues que
han sido fallidas por eso también de
continuo de violencia pues no no no
vamos a poder hacer mucho en cambio aquí
en el estudio esas políticas de paz de
seguridad
tienen tonos de cambiar para el próximo
gobierno que llega hay un programa que
de pronto represente algún tipo de
cambio para esa política que ha
mantenido el gobierno colombiano a lo
largo de estos años el gobierno electo
ha permitido cambio en diferentes
aspectos uno de los aspectos que más se
ha deteriorado en el país es el aspecto
de seguridad y uno de los aspectos en
donde hay más déficit de implementación
de políticas públicas es en el tema de
paz
por ende uno encontraría previsible qué
el gobierno electo va a ser diferentes
movimientos para buscar dar un timonazo
a las políticas de seguridad y de paz
sobre todo dando un enfoque de seguridad
humana y de derechos humanos
es todavía muy temprano para saber el
alcance y dimensiones de ese de ese
proyecto pero lo que sabemos es que es
urgente una intervención pronta de la
institucionalidad para superar muchas de
estas lógicas que se repiten y se
repiten sin ninguna solución de
continuidad desde su análisis camilo
cuál sería el paso correcto en ese orden
de ideas garantizar seguridad o
garantizar presencia del estado que es
un gran problema que tiene el estado
colombiano a lo largo de los años no
puede llegar a todos los rincones ya
todas las zonas apartadas del país para
usted cuál sería el primer paso en mi
concepto el problema grande no es de
presencia del estado el estado en
realidad ha hecho presencia de
diferencia en diferentes partes del
territorio el gran problema es qué tipo
de presencia es el estado con qué
énfasis y hasta qué punto el poder civil
y el estado de derecho realmente rige en
en lo que llamamos colombia entonces
digamos que más allá del problema de
presencia del estado es un problema de
políticas públicas de intencionalidad de
que comunidades que lugares se van a
proteger bajo el prisma del estado de
derecho y como y hasta cuando el estado
se va a comprometer realmente en dar una
continuidad a estas políticas
daniela regreso al informe como tal hay
un punto destacado que caracteriza a
este informe de la comisión de la verdad
presentada en colombia y es el capítulo
en el que se habla de las mujeres de
ciertos grupos minoritarios y también de
los grupos étnicos que deja de elección
este informe sobre estos tres puntos en
particular que es completamente novedoso
para un informe de este tipo a nivel
internacional
en efecto digamos es novedoso hay muchas
expectativas sobre estos capítulos
también hay que tener en cuenta pues que
tuvimos personas como muy muy capaces en
la materia alejandra miller en el tema
de género patricia en el tema de la
comisionada particia en el tema étnico
entonces digamos que eso sí siendo un
precedente
el conflicto se vive muy diferente
cuando se des mujer cuando se es negro
cuando se es indígena y la mayor parte
de relatos hegemónicos que se han
construido alrededor del conflicto no
dan cuenta de estas diferencias y han
sido organizaciones como la ruta
pacífica mujeres
cisma entre otras muchas que han sentado
como recuperar jazz y la comisión creo
que está haciendo un esfuerzo
justamente por visibilizar toda esta
construcción de mejor y este lado camilo
lecciones que dejaste este informe de
esta comisión tan particular tres años
de trabajo ya hablamos de las cifras de
la cantidad de casos que ha estudiado a
lo largo de ancho de colombia lecciones
que pueda dejar para escenarios
similares en otras partes del mundo
bueno creo que la implementación de
enfoques tiene una particularidad muy
especial para dar un diagnóstico sobre
las causas pero también para dar una
lectura de la extensión de los efectos
en las diferentes comunidades y las
diferentes subjetividades en conflictos
que son complejos más no confusos como
el conflicto colombiano sobre todo
conflictos de larga duración creo que el
tema de exilio y poder entender que las
verdades no están digámoslo así
solamente dentro de los territorios en
los conflictos sino que muchas de esas
verdades salen del país y se preservan
en otros lugares es muy importante el
enfoque de curso de vida que da cuenta
de un problema intergeneracional y como
la violencia ha sido transmitiendo de
una generación tras otra y como no ha
habido solución y se ha generado un
mayor énfasis en esos problemas en la
niñez y en también los adultos mayores y
por último creería yo entre muchos otros
pues el tema de impunidad es un tema muy
importante porque es un tema que hace
énfasis en una causa y consecuencia del
conflicto que es la ausencia de
respuesta institucional frente a las más
graves es que dejado las víctimas a
merced de diferentes
perpetradores pero además que no ha
puesto fin a las formas organizadas de
hacer violencia en nuestro país me
quedan ya pocos minutos para terminar el
programa
quiero pasar a hablar de las
recomendaciones que hace este informe
sólo por mencionar algunas
habla de la necesidad de que el estado
colombiano negoció con otros grupos
armados también una modificación en el
proceso de selección o de escogencia del
fiscal para garantizar que no haya
impunidad y que haya división de poderes
y completa imparcialidad a la hora de
juzgar a las personas que están inmersas
en este conflicto entre otros tantos
puntos que deja esto plasmado en este
informe daniela como base del
seguimiento de lo que pase de aquí en
adelante como es la implementación
porque son sugerencias no es una
obligatoriedad llevar a cabo todas las
recomendaciones que hace el informe pero
quién puede garantizar que algunos
puntos sean tenidos en cuenta que sean
llevados a cabo que está el estado
colombiano pueda desarrollarlos y
también que la sociedad pues sea propia
algunas de ellas y las pueda
llevar a cabo pues según lo anunciaron
justamente los comisionados esto estará
a cargo no solamente del gobierno de la
rama judicial
entre otros órganos pues del estado sino
también de la sociedad civil se dan
recomendaciones para radios voluntarias
me imagino que organizaciones de base
entre otras entonces pues digamos que
asegurar su cumplimiento va a ser
complicado
sobre todo porque una cosa es cuando uno
hace recomendaciones y otras cosas
cuando lo viabilizadas y pues tienes un
costo estimado de lo que te podría
costar y realmente las voluntades
políticas también para poder implementar
reformas pero algunas de las que
mencionas son reformas que yo creo que
son urgentes como la disip la fiscalía
los mecanismos de elección de los
órganos de control
entre varios otros que pude ver mientras
leía por encima las recomendaciones sin
duda seguramente el gobierno de petro
tomara varias de éstas y las
implementarán los que seguramente le
parezcan fiables pero antes de pasar a
las conclusiones sus impresiones sobre
estas recomendaciones viables las podrán
ver los colombianos materializadas que
piensa usted uno de los grandes secretos
del éxito de una comisión de la verdad
no es solamente su investigación sino
cómo traduce lo hallado en unas
recomendaciones que sean viables muchas
de las recomendaciones a las cuales ha
llegado la comisión de la verdad parten
de muchas reclamaciones que han hecho
las víctimas las organizaciones e
incluso muchísimas personas conocedores
académicos de diferentes temas el tema
de los equilibrios de poder de la falta
de independencia de las partes de las
autoridades judiciales los problemas de
estigmatización de políticas públicas
que generan vulnerabilidad y
discriminación las comunidades son
problemas que no son digamos la ciones
elixir único de la comisión de la verdad
sino que parten también de muchos años
de insistencia de la emm ya de la
ciencia pero también de las víctimas con
respecto a sus experiencias en el
conflicto armado entonces uno creería
que esto quiere decir que las
recomendaciones se deben traducir a unas
políticas públicas concretas para poder
realmente dar cumplimiento a cabalidad
el acuerdo ya un minuto para finalizar
el programa daniela conclusiones que va
a pasar de aquí en adelante siempre lo
digo no tenemos la bola de cristal para
saber el futuro menos del futuro de
colombia en torno a este tema que sigue
para este país después de este informe
la comisión de la verdad pues
seguramente seguirán las luchas por la
memoria
y pues esperemos ir ampliando los
consensos sobre lo que nos ha pasado y
sobre todo sobre la ruta para salir de
lo que no hay que acordar sobre
digamos cosas muy personales de las
personas sino sobre prácticas que nos
permitan reconciliarnos y llevar
y por este lado camelo creo que se abre
en tres tres caminos el primero la
implementación y un comité de
seguimiento que realmente se traduzcan
las medidas materiales segundo el de la
asimilación de la sociedad y la
pedagogía en cuanto a los hallazgos de
la comisión de la verdad y tercero el de
la implementación de las políticas
públicas de paz acorde con lo encontrado
a camilo ya daniela les agradezco por
haber llevado este análisis a la
audiencia de france 24 en américa
latina' ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales siguen con nosotros
[Música]